one warning that's it you gave me one
you may have seen the videos on social
media
or experienced it firsthand
according to airlines the association of
flight attendants cwa union and the faa
disruptive unruly and violent passengers
have become a serious problem
last year the faa reported a record high
number of unruly passenger reports
although incidents have fallen since
spiking earlier in the year today's rate
remains above pre-pandemic levels this
past year starting at the beginning of
2021 has been the most difficult and
consistently dangerous time in our
careers we have been kicked punched
spit at
had trash thrown at us and it's it's
taken its toll
in a survey taken last summer of 5 000
flight attendants from 30 airlines 85
said they had dealt with unruly
passengers in 2021 with over half saying
they'd experienced five or more such
incidents and 17 saying they were
involved in an incident that got
physical
one solution that's gaining traction is
a federal no-fly list unruly passengers
who've been convicted of in-flight
offenses that they'd be put on a special
no-fly list and and not be allowed to
fly on any airline
according to the faa 70 of last year's
passenger reports were related to mass
related incidents so far this year 65
percent of incidents are related to
masks
now with in-flight and airport mask
mandates slated to be lifted in march is
a national no-fly list really needed
earlier this year the ceo of delta
airlines at bastian wrote to the u.s
justice department asking the agency to
create a national no-fly list for anyone
convicted of disrupting a flight
bastion road a no-fly list of unruly
passengers will help prevent future
incidents and serve as a strong symbol
of the consequences of not complying
with crew member instructions on
commercial aircraft all the airlines
over the last year or two as these
conflicts and flights and disputes over
masks have ramped up they've been
administering their own lists of people
that they won't have on board anymore
delta said it had put nearly 1900 people
on its list for refusing to comply with
masking requirements and submitted more
than 900 ban names to the tsa to pursue
civil penalties
the concern is though that they don't
and really can't share that information
so somebody has caused a problem on a
united flight
and they can no longer fly united
because of the airlines policies you
know in theory they can book their next
flight on delta where they may end up
being disrupted again delta said that
while such incidents of bad behavior
represent just a small fraction of the
overall flights on delta the rate of
incidence on the airline has increased
nearly 100 percent since 2019. flight
attendants are absolutely not willing to
accept this as the new normal so what
they're saying is make it stop you also
see this in the fact that across the
board their flight attendants are just
not willing to pick up the voluntary
overtime hours that they were before the
pandemic and so the public saw that in
many flight cancellations in the fall
and even over the holidays in 2021 the
faa said it initiated nearly 1100
investigations into early passengers
which is more than the previous seven
years combined flight attendants will
say a lot of these incidents don't
necessarily have anything to do with
masks you know some of them involve
alcohol and some of them just seem to
defy all explanation
the binding administration has voiced
its support for the idea anything
besides zero is an unacceptable rate
but not everyone is in favor of a
national no-fly list
recently a group of republican senators
wrote a letter to attorney general mayor
garland suggesting that such a law could
infringe on civil rights the republican
senators who oppose the letter you know
basically they argue that it would give
the department of justice too much
authority to create a list and there
wouldn't necessarily be
transparency and clarity into who would
be on the list and that this really is
something that should come through
congress the senators wrote the creation
of this list by doj would result in a
severe restriction on the ability of
citizens to fully exercise their
constitutional right to engage in
interstate transportation the senators
also noted that since most of last
year's unruly passenger incidents were
mass-related the no-fly list would
unfairly target massless passengers
the senators wrote creating a federal
no-fly list for unruly passengers who
are skeptical of this mandate would
seemingly equate them to terrorists who
seek to actively take the lives of
americans and perpetrate attacks on the
homeland you know they also complain
that it sort of equates people who are
objecting to the mass mandate to
terrorists which you know they say is
unfair and overblown you know that's not
quite exactly what delta had proposed
you know it's not necessarily that delta
had proposed everyone who won't wear
masks should be
banned from flying but obviously it
would be
um controversial
but how realistic is a no-fly list now
that the unruly passenger rate has
fallen since its dramatic spike last
year what's more mask mandates which
were one of the biggest points of
friction last year are coming to an end
in march this is an issue that has been
so politicized
that people who want to wear masks and
people who don't want to wear masks are
both in conflict with each other and so
sometimes the aggressors on the planes
are the people who are so angry that
other people just won't follow the rules
the agency with the authority to extend
the mask mandate the tsa has said
nothing thus far about another extension
last december the tsa extended its mass
mandate for another three months to
combat the surge in omicron variant
cases
[Music]